[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون
برنامج اخباري خاص ومتنوع وبقاع سريع
ومختلف جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبين
العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم والصوره
الكامله البدايه من العناوين
السعوديه وايران اتفاق مفاجئ على استئناف
العلاقات وكلمه السر بكين ثلاث جبهات
مشتعله في بخموت واحده للقتال واخرى
للسجال وثالثه للتسميه وفي ملفات الساعه
60 المملكه المتحده مفككه عظمه بريطانيا
في خطر والسبب النزعه القوميه خلطه
تطبيقيه تيك توك السريه سلاحه بوجه الحظر
الزمن الربح والانتشار
[موسيقى]
برعايه الله الصينيه اتفقت السعوديه
وايران على استئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه
وعلى اعاده فتح سفرتي البلدين خلال شهرين
في حسب بيان ثلاثي مشترك صدر في بكين
ونقلته وكاله الانباء السعوديه احترام
سياده الدول وعدم التدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه كان من بين الامور التي اتفق
عليها الجانبان كما تم التوافق على تفعيل
اتفاقيه التعاون الامني الموقعه عام 2001
اتفاقيه اخرى ستفعل بحسب البيان الثلاثي
وهي اتفاقيه التعاون في مجال الاقتصادي
والت والاستثمار وهي الموقعه في عام
1998 الدول الثلاث اعربت عن حرصها على بدل
كافه الجهود لتعزيز السلمي والامن
الاقليمي والدوليه اذا هو اتفاقنا تكلل
بالنجاح بعد سلسله من المباحثات بين
البلدين عقدت في كل من العراق وسلطنه عمان
على مدار السنتين الماضيتين وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان اكد ان
استئناف العلاقات مع ايران ياتي من رؤيه
المملكه لتفضيل الحوار الوزير السعوديه
قال ان المصير الواحد لدول المنطقه يجعل
من الضرورات بناء نموذج للاستقرار بدوره
اعرب مستشار الامن الوطني السعودي الدكتور
مساعد بن محمد العيبان عن امل المملكه في
استمرار الحوار البناء مع ايران وفقا
للمرتكزات والاسس التي تضمنها اتفاق
استئناف العلاقات وقال مستشار الامن
الوطني السعودي انه تم الاتفاق على فتح
صفحه جديده مع طهران قائمه على المواثيق
الدوليه واشار العيبان الى ان تطوير
العلاقات مع ايران ياتي من منطلق تمسك
المملكه بمبادئ حسن الجوار واكد انه تمت
مناقشه اسباب الخلافات مع ايران وسبل
معالجتها
[موسيقى]
هلا
امينو مجلس الامن القومي الايرانيه علي
شمخاني قال عقب الاعلان عن الاتفاق على
استئناف العلاقات بين طهران والرياض ان
تعزيز العلاقات مع السعوديه سيؤدي لمزيد
من الاستقرار واضاف ان بلاده تتطلع الى
المستقبل في العلاقات مع السعوديه وتابع
شمخاني ان المحادثات مع السعوديه كانت
صريحه وشفافه وبناءه واشهد بدور الصين
باعاده بناء العلاقات مع السعوديه ومن
جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه الايراني حسين
امير عبد الله ان استئناف العلاقات مع
السعوديه يوفروا امكانيات كبيره للمنطقه
وقال ان السياسه امن الجوار امر محوري
وهناك مزيد من الخطوات الدبلوماسيه في
المنطقه ينضم الينا من لندن عارف ناصر
الباحث في الشان الايراني اهلا بك اذا ما
الذي دفع ايران الى هذه الخطوه في هذا
التوقيت بالذات
تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهدين العربيه الكرام
الواقع هنالك مجموعه من النقاط الاساسيه
ممكن اخذها بعين الاعتبار اهمها
يعني الملف النووي وكذلك
الحراك الثوري الاخيره الذي شاهدته ايران
والعزله الدوليه التي ربما صارت عليها
ايران خلال
شهور السته الماضيه اعتقد دفعت ايران
بانها تخرج من الانسداد الداخلي لانسداد
الداخلي الذي كان مسؤول عن فشل جميع
العلاقات على الصعيد
المنطقه وحتى على صعيد الدولي هنا اتحدث
عن الانسداد الذي كان بين المجلس الاعلى
للامن القومي وبين البرلمان وبين الحكومه
بمعنى اي من هذه الاطراف لم يكن له صلاحيه
الغرام لذلك انا اعتقد بان حضور علي
شمخاني بهذه المفاوضات كان بواعزم علي
خامنئي وبالتالي هذا القرار
كان من خامني نفسه لذلك هنالك خروج من
منطقه الثوره الذي ربما تمسك بخامل
والاحتكام الى منطقه الدوله وما هي
الضمانات التي يجب ان تقدمها ايران لاثبات
حسن النوايا وفضح هذه الصفحه الجديده مع
السعوديه ودول منطقه ككل
اعتقد بان على الاقل البيان الذي صدر يبين
بان هنالك حرفيه عاليه
كانت لدى الجانب السعودي بمعنى نحن نتحدث
عن تفاهم وبيان مشترك وليس اتفاق
ربما دولي مشترك
ثلاثيه او ثنائي الجانب الثاني ان يربط
هذا التفاهم بسقف زمني مداح شهرين ولا
تستانف العلاقات مباشره ايضا له
رساله واضحه
ارادها الجانب السعودي
ويبين بان الجانب السعودي اراد او يريد
عمليا الافعال ولا ان يكتفي الجانب
الايراني بالاقوال لكنما واجابه على سؤالك
اعتقد بان وجود الطرف الصيني هو الضامن
لهذا الاتفاق وفيما يبدو هو ضامن لانه
لديه مص الح مشتركه بين الطرفين ويتضمن
هذا القرار ايضا تفعيل الى ربما جوانب
اقتصاديه قد يستفيد منها الصين ايضا هو
الضامنه للخطوات المقبله تعني
الفعل انا اعتقد بان الصين ستكون خلال
الشهرين القادمين ستكون الضامن الى تفعيل
مجموعه من الاتفاقات بين الجانب الايراني
والجانب السعودي اهمها اتفاقيات
واحد وهي التي تتعلق بالجانب الامني لذلك
ربما سنشهد عده خطوات لكنما من المبكر
الان ان ربما نتفاعل كثيرا بهذه الخطوه
الخطوه هذه يجب ان
[موسيقى]
تقترن بالافعال حتى نجد ربما صدى هذا هذا
الاتفاق واعتقد بان الملف اليمني هو اهم
الملفات بهذا الخصوص
سيد عارف كيف نقرا الترحيب الامريكي
تحديدا في هذا التوقيت في ظل العلاقات
الشائكه والمعقده مع ايران
اعتقد بان الترحيب الامريكي ناتج من كون
ايضا احدى اطراف هذا هذا التغير المفاجئ
للانسداد السياسي الداخلي هي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه بمعنى ان هنالك مجموعه
من المفاوضات الان تجري بين الطرف
الامريكي والجانب الايراني بواساطه عمانيه
للافراج عن الرهائن وبالتالي اعتقد ان هذا
الامر لا يختصر على
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني هنالك اتفاقات
بين الجانب الامريكي والايراني واتفاق
ثالث ايضا بين الوكاله الدوليه الطاقه
الذريه والجانب الايراني وبالتالي اعتقد
بان النظام الايراني الان قرر بان يعيد
بعض ترتيب بعض العلاقات سواء على الصعيد
الاوروبي او الصعيد الامريكي او صعيد دول
المنطقه ومع هذه الترتيبات لو تطابقت
الخطوات المقبله مع الاعلانات كيف سيفيد
ذلك ايران وشعب ايران بالتحديد
بالفعل يعني هذا الامر له له بعد خارج
وبعد داخليا بعد الداخلي اليوم سمعنا مثلا
المولى عبد الحميد اشاره بان هنالك انسداد
وصل على الصعيد الداخلي ايضا بمعنى اعتقد
بان اذا ما غورنا
يعني لم يكن هنالك تغييرات داخليه فاعتقد
بان ربما هذه الجوانب الخارجيه لا تستطيع
وحدها ان تغير من مصير الشعب الايراني
هنالك
حاجه ماسه الى تغييرات جذريه داخل النظام
الايراني ربما عمليه استفتاء شعبي او ربما
تغيرات
جذريه
بهيكل الحكومه وحتى ربما اعاده كثير من من
الاطراف السياسيه التي ابعدها النظام
الايراني الى المشهد وهذا ايضا في يعني
تشير بعض التسريبات بان النظام الايراني
الان يعمل على الصعيد الداخلي ايضا الى
عمليه ربما عفو عام يطال حتى المعارضين
بالداخل والخارج واجراءات داخليه جذريه
كما يتحدث
بعض التسريبات نعم اشكرك جزيل الشكرك معنا
من لندن الباحث في الشان الايراني عارف
نصر
[موسيقى]
وايضا لمناقشه ابرز التصريحات الرسميه
السعوديه ومناقشتها مع تفاصيل استئناف
العلاقات السعوديه الايرانيه انضم الينا
من جده محمد السعد الكاتب الصحفي السعودي
اهلا بك ما هي الاولويات بالنسبه للسعوديه
التي يجب ان تظهرها ايران لتدلل على ان
هذه الخطوه يمكن استكمالا ويمكن تعزيزها
اعتقد ان لدينا خارطه
مدتها 60 يوما تبدا من تاريخ اليوم هذه هي
60 يوم ستثبت فيها ايران حسن نواياها
والحقيقه انها جديره بهذا الاتفاق وقدرتها
على المضيء فيه لان كل التجارب السابقه
الحقيقه كانت تجارب غير جيده في التعاطي
مع الايرانيين ودائما يكون
لديهم اجندات مختلفه ومتغيره نتيجه حسابات
داخليه معقده ولكن نحن اليوم الحقيقه في
انتظار ان تلتزم ايران بالشروط
وبالاتفاق
المبدعي الذي وقع في الصين وبالتالي
المنطقه كلها ستترقب السلوك الايراني اذا
كان سلوكا ايجابيا ودون روايه حسنه ليس في
العلاقه مع السعوديه فحسب ولكن ايضا في
المناطق الاشتباك العديده في العالم
العربي والتي لايراني للاسف تواجد كثير
فيها وتواجد غير جيد في في سوريا وفي
لبنان وفي اليمن وبالتالي الجميع في
انتظار تحسن هذا السلوك وايضا
السعوديه تتوقع ان يكون هناك اراده
ايرانيه مماثله ذات نوايا حسنه تريد ان
تطبق هذا الاتفاق وتمضي به قدما نحو
الامام السعوديه دائما ما تقول بان ليس
لديها اجندات مضاده لدوله جاره في المنطقه
مثل مثل ايران الجغرافيا تعزمنا بالتعامل
مع ايران كدوله جاره الى شك ولا يمكن
ازالتها وازاحتها من المنطقه وبالتالي هذا
الاتفاق يعكس النيه السعوديه الصادقه في
الوصول ليس بالعلاقه السعوديه الايرانيه
وانما بالمنطقه باكملها نحو
التزمت السعوديه بالتفاوض والدبلوماسيه
وبالصبر الطويل من اجل الوصول الى هذا
الاتفاق والحقيقه اننا يعني في في انتظار
نتائج ايجابيه لان المنطقه لم تعد الحقيقه
في احتمال لاي تعكير ولاي
تازم العالم اليوم يمر بازمه امنيه دوليه
كبيره جدا نتيجه الحرب
الاوكرانيه الروسيه او بالتالي هذا
الانعكاس الكبير على الاقليم قد يفجروا في
اي لحظه
فكره نزع فتيل للتعزيم من من المنطقه
الحقيقه ان فكره ممتازه لصالح شعوب
المنطقه وبالتالي مساعده هذه الدول وهذه
الشعوب نحو تقدم اذا افاقت تنمويه
واقتصاديه كبيره المنطقه عانت الحقيقه من
فشل طويل لازمها بعد ما يسمى بالخريف
العربي
ودفعت المنطقه نتائجه من دمائها ومن
حياتها ومن اقتصادها
ان الوقت لكي تلتفت هذه الشعوب وهذه الدول
الى الداخل وتبني اقتصاداتها السعوديه
لديها رؤيه اقتصاديه مهمه واجتماعيه وهذه
الرؤيه اتت نتائجها
الامير محمد بن سلمان ولي العهد في احدى
المنتديات بانه يامل ان يرى المنطقه
باكملها ان تتحول الى اوروبا جديده
حول
ياتي بالنوايا وانما بالاعمال وبتصفير
المشاكل ونحن نامل الحقيقه في السعوديه ان
تحذوا ايران نحو دور المنطقه
باستثمار في التنميه وليس الاستثمار في
التخريب او الارهاب الذي يعني عرفت به
ايران محمد لو تحدثنا بخطوات عمليه عن مده
الستين يوما هل ستشمل محادثات بشان هذه
الملفات كلها للمنطقه هل ستشمل محادثات
بشان امن السعوديه هل ماذا ستشمل عدا عن
فتح السفارتين في الرياض وفي طهران
لفتح السفاريتين سيكون اخر نتائج هذه 60
يوما
ضامن الصيني اعتقد انه سيكون عليه كلفه
هائله في متابعه التزام ايران بتحررها من
فكره
والتحول نحو فكره دوله فكره دوله يلزمها
بان تكون رغماتيه وان تكون سياسيه وان
تتعاطى مع الملفات بروح الجيره وليس بروح
الثوره وبليس بروح يعني التدخل في اشياء
من الداخلي الدول العربيه
للاسف انها تنظر للعالم بعيون عربيه ولا
تنظر للعالم بعيون ايرانيه لتحاول ان
تخترق العالم وان يكون لديها اوراق لعب
قادره على يعني ابتزاز العالم بها من خلال
سيطرتها على بعض العواصم او بعض الدول
العربيه كالعراق او او سوريا او لبنان
واليمن وحان
الوقت نحو حدودها الاقليميه تاركه الشان
العربي لاهله العرب قادرون على حل ازماتهم
دون التدخل تدخل ايراني وهذه كانت
الحقيقه كانوا يريدون التدخل في كانوا
وحاولوا وبضوا قدما حقيقه بالتدخل في
الشؤون العربيه وكان موقف المملكه العربيه
السعوديه موقفا صارما لن نسمح بالتدخل
الايراني في اي شان دوله عربيه وهذا يعتبر
مساسا بالامن القومي السعودي مباشره بان
اي تاخر ايراني في اي عصر عربيه او في اي
دوله عربيه يمس المملكه بشكل مباشر
يعني خطير وبالتالي السعوديه تقف وقفت
طوال تلك العقود الماضيه بالمرصاد لمثل
هذه التدخلات اعتقد اننا امام منعطف مهم
واعتقد اننا امام فرصه تاريخيه للمنطقه
المدير قدما نحو المستقبل نحو الاستثمار
في يعني حياه مدنيه
وحياه اكثر رفاهيه بعدما عانت هذه المنطقه
من صعوبات ومن حروب متتاليه منذ العام
1978 من اصول يعني الثوره الايرانيه الى
طهران اعتقد ان انه حان اليوم
للترجل عن ذلك الفكر الثوري
ويعني الايمان بفكر الدوله وفكر العلاقات
الدبلوماسيه
وايضا التعاطي مع الخلافات بروح التفاوض
والتشاور وليس بروح القتال والتعارض نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك من جد محمد السعد الكاتب
الصحفي السعودي
معاركه تشتعل لكن ماذا عن باخمه اخرى
الساعه ما عاد دقيقه
الامدادات عنها ويصبح ذلك تكرار سينيالو
ماريو بول مساله وقت فقط
تقع مدينه باخبوت على نهر باخ بوتفكاش
مالي مقاطعه دونيسك شرق اوكرانيا تبعد نحو
50080 كيلومترا عن العاصمه كييف يعود
تاسيسها الى عام
1571 بان حكم قيصر روسيا ايفانا رهيب تبلغ
مساحتها نحو واحد واربعين كيلو متر مربعا
اما سكانها فقد بلغ عددهم نحو 71 وفقا
لاخر احصائيه قبل الهجوم الروسي فيما فر
نحو 90% منهم بعد الحرب بحسب سلطات
المقاطعه تركيبتها السكانيه متنوعه بين
الاوكرانيين وذوي الاصول الروسيه كما توجد
فيها اقليه اخرى كالبيلاروسيين والارمن
وتعد باكموت احدى اكبر مراكز صناعات
الالات الثقيله في اوكرانيا كما تعتمد
بشكل اساسي على استخراج الملح الصخري حيث
تقع مناجم الملح في مدينه
سوليدار الواقعه على بعد نحو عشره
كيلومترات والتي احكمت القوات الروسيه
قبضتها عليها مؤخرا
واشهر جعلت
اطول معركه في اوكرانيا خسائر الطرفين تعد
بالالاف بينما تحسب المكاسب على الارض
بالامتار لكن ما سر الاصرار على بخموت
وزير الدفاع الامريكي اقلل من اهميه
المدينه
كشفت الاسباب واشنطن لا تريد رؤيتك تنجرف
وراء معركه استنزاف الفائز فيها خاسر
التقارير نفسها تحدثت عن رغبه قاده الجيش
الاوكراني في الانسحاب الا ان معارضه
زيلينسكيت اجلت القرار حتى في اوكرانيا
بخموت لم تكن بهذه الاهميه قبل اسابيع
الاعلام الاوكراني تحدث عن تكلفه صمودا
تفوق اهميه بخمس لكن خطابات الاخيره عادت
لتجعله تجعل المدينه حركته الاولى ربما هي
مناوره عسكريه لاستدراج المزيد من القوات
الروسيه زيلينسكي برره قراره بكون بخموت
اخر خطوط الدفاع قبل
اكرام وهو لا يخفي رغبته في ربح الوقت قبل
وصول الدبابه الالمانيه الا ان بروجين له
راي اخر
بطني
يبدو منطقيا لكن هل وقع بروكين بدوره في
الفخارت من بخموت معركتها الوحيده ولاجلها
تاخذه معركه موازيه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تنافس تحول الى الصراع وبوتا لا يزال
متفرجا تكلفه الصمود في باخموت لا تخفيها
باغمر ولا ثياب
اتحدث عن مقتل احد عشر الفا اوكراني خلال
الشهر الماضي الا انا فايتنر تسعى لتجنيد
المزيد من المساجين بينما تجد اوكرانيا
نفسها امام خسائر قد يصعب تعويضها
[موسيقى]
اسمه المدينه وعنوانه معركه يختزل ايضا
جذور الصراع بين اوكرانيا الكيان القائم
بذاته واوكرانيا غير القادره عن الانفصال
عن عمقها الروسي المدينه تعتبر اقدم مدن
دنيا واطلق عليها زمن روسيا القيصريه اسمه
مع ميلاد جمهوريه اوكرانيا الاشتراكيات
تغير اسم المدينه الى
نسبه الى احد اشهر رموز الاشتراكيه الروس
وبعد احداث الميدان انتفض المولون لروسيا
ضد منع اللغه الروسيه في اوكرانيا وسيطر
الانفصاليون على المدينه لعده اشهر قبل ان
تستعيدها اوكرانيا في سبتمبر 2015 في
السنه التاليه اصدر البرلمان الاوكراني
قانون مكافحه الاشتراكيه وهو ما سمح
بتغيير الكثير من اسماء المدن والشوارع
وازاله التماثيل الروسيه بعدها صوت مجلس
المدينه بالاغلبيه على تغيير اسم المدينه
لتصبح نسبه الى نهر بخموتكا الذي يمر
عبرها القرار لم يعجب سكانها الناطقين
باللغه الروسيه كونه لم يعكس رغبه السكان
عبر استفتاء مباشر ومدينتهم كانت وستبقى
كل الانظار متجهه نحو بخمت لكن في الوقت
نفسه مدينه اخرى جنوبا تشهد نفس المصير
مدينه مارينكا في اقليم دومباس 120 كم
جنوبيه
ومره اخرى روسيا غيرت الخطه وتتجه نحو
تطويقها التحدي في مارينكا يدور بين جيوش
النظاميه الفرقه الاوكرانيه المحموله
جوالنا رقم 79 والفوز 255 من القوات
المسلحه الروسيه مارينكا كان يسكنها عشاره
الاف اوكراني تحولت بالكامل الى ركام
والمعارك مستمره صور الدمار في مارينكا
تعكس شراسه القتال الروس وصفوا التمسك
الاوكرانيين بالمدينه بالاستماته من اجل
الاطلال والاوكرانيون يرون صمودهم في
المدينه رساله لكل من توقع سقوط باخمه
القريب
[موسيقى]
الاسباب مختلفه والخوف واحد عظمه بريطانيا
العظمى في خطر نموا اوسع في القوميه سواء
كانت اسكتلنديه متمثله في نزعه استقلاليه
جديده قديمه او القوميه الانجليزيه التي
انعكست في
وبموت الملكه اليزابيث وفضائح الاسره
الملكيه فضاءلت هيبه ورمزيه التاج لشعوب
المملكه المختلفه هيبه تمثلت عندما خرجت
الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه عن خط الحياد
ودعت الاسكتلنديين للتفكير مليا في
المستقبل قبل استفتاء الاستقلال عام 2014
حتى دول الكومنويلث التي حافظت على
الرمزيه الدوليه للتاج البريطاني توزعت
بين من غادر مثل باربيدس ومن يدرس خيار
المغادره كاستراليا ونيوزيلندا
من عباءه لندن ان حدث له عواقب امنيه ايضا
فالحزب الوطني
اكد انه لن يسمح للغواصات النوويه
البريطانيه الاربع ان تبقى في قاعده
فاسلين من المخاطر الى اسبابها
الديموغرافيه الدينيه اصبحت عاملا ضد وحده
بريطانيا فقبل 100 عام تم انشاء ايرلندا
الشماليه على اساس انه سيضم الغالبيه
البروتستانتيه والمؤيده للبقاء في ظل لندن
سبتمبر 2022 حدث تاريخي فقد الوحدويون
البروتستانت الاغلبيه وباتو اقليه امام
القوميين الكاثوليك الراغبين في الاتحاد
مع جمهوريه ايرلندا اقتصاديا كان بمثابه
القشه التي قسمت ظهر البعير لكن تراجع
الصناعه البريطانيه يعود لحقبه
الثمانينيات حين كانت غلاسكو وبالباست
مركزين لصناعه بناء السفن اصابع اللوم
تتجه نحو المراه الحديديه
خلال عقد من حكمها انخفض الانتاج الصناعي
في بريطانيا بنسبه تسعه في المئه بينما
ارتفع بنسب كبيره في دول مثل فرنسا
واليابان
استمراره المملكه المتحده كتحد من اربع
دول انجلترا واسكتلندا وويلز وايرلندا
الشماليه مهدد من قبل القوى الانفصاليه
فاستقلال اسكتلندا لم يتحقق في استفتاء
عام 2014 حيث صوت 55 في المئه لصالح
البقاء في المملكه المتحده ويبدو انه
سيصبح القضيه الانتخابيه الرئيسيه لسنوات
عديده قادمه مع تنامي مشاعر القوميه
وتراجعي المؤيدين للبقاء الى خمسين في
المئه كما جر البريكزيت كوتلندا خارج
اوروبا بالرغم من تصويت مواطنيها ضد
الانسحاب من الاتحاد الاوروبي وما تلاه من
تبعات اقتصاديه مكلفه الوضع في ايرلندا
الشماليه من جهته غير مشجع فحزب الشنفين
الكاثوليكي المؤيد للانفصال يقود لاول مره
مجلس المقاطعه ويضع حلم
توحيد شطري الجزيره الايرلنديه في سياسته
كثيرون هنا يقدرنا ان القوميه قد تكون
اللاعب الابرز في السنوات المقبله على
مستوى تحديد وحده المملكه
الانقسام معاكسه تضارب المصالح بين
مقاطعات بريطانيا الاربع وتجلى في نتائج
التصويت على
انجلترا راى القوميون الانجليزي ان الخروج
من الاتحاد الاوروبي انتصار نفسي عظيم
الانجليز كانوا الاكثر حماسه باغلبيه
اغلبيه
53.4% في اسكتلندا اي 62% البقاء في
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبعد خروج بريطانيا من
الاتحاد الاوروبي عبر الاسكتلنديون عن عدم
رضاهم فاز الحزب الوطني الاسكتلندي
المطالب بالاستقلال عن التاج البريطانيين
بسته وخمسين مقعدا برلمانيا في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه البريطانيه لعام 2015 قبل ان
يحقق اغلبيه كبيره في الانتخابات
البرلمانيه في العام الذي تلاها 2016 في
ايرلندا الشماليه تفوق الجمهوريين كاثوليك
الراغبون
لجمهوريه ايرلندا على الوحدويون الوحدويين
البروتستانت الموالين البريطانيه التفوق
كان بنسبه
55.8 من المصوطين لخيار البقاء تحت مظله
بروكسيل لا تزالوا الاغلبيه في ويلز تدعم
البقاء مع بريطانيا على الرغم من استفاده
ويلز من الاتحاد الاوروبي بحوالي
245 مليون جنيه استرليني سنويا حينها
واقعا انعكس في تصويت
52.5% من الوالدين لصالح الخروج من
الاتحاد الاوروبي
الولايات المتحده والصين تاريخ طويل من
التجسس والاتهامات المتبادله الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
لاول مره في تاريخ الصين
رئيسا لولايه ثالثه مدتها خمس سنوات
ادى اليمين الدستوريه بعد تصويت البرلمان
بالاجماع على انتخابه تاتي ياتي هذا
اليمين مع توترات كبيره وبعد يوم من اتهام
الرئيس الصيني لواشنطن بمحاوله تطويق
الصين وقمعها حذر وزير خارجيته من ان
البلدين يتجهان نحو تصادم حتمي خطر لا
مثيل له هكذا تصف الاستخبارات الوطنيه
الامريكيه بكين شبكه سي ان ان تقول ان
مجتمع الاستخبارات الامريكيه الان هو من
يدفع الى التصعيد تحاول الاستخبارات
التاثير في نظره الامريكيين للصين ومن هنا
تتصاعد التحذيرات من تيك توك بحسب الان بل
وتم حظر
مقاطع تصل مدتها الى 20 دقيقه وهي ضعف
المده القصوى في تيك توك اذا التطبيق الذي
اصبح اعلى التطبيقات تنزيلا في العالم عام
2022 بحسب شركه تاور يملك خلطه سريه وايضا
خطه قضائيه وكاله بلومبرج كشفت عن توظيف
تيك توك 60 محاميا استعدادا لمواجهه
القيود التنظيميه الامريكيه
للمزيد حول هذه الازمه لتيك توك ينضم
الينا الدكتور انس النجداوي الاكاديمي
والمستشار في اداره الاعمال الرقميه
والتقنيه اذا هذه الخلطه السريه بين المده
الزمنيه الانتشار وايضا المنافسه في نفس
الوقت هل هي خطه
لمواجهه هذا الحظر المحتمل الامريكي
مساء الخير يا حنين والمشاهدين الكرام
طبعا بدايه لابد نعترف انه تطبيق تيك توك
حقق نجاح كبير
وبشكل سريع جدا خرافي ايضا بالنسبه
للتطبيقات الاخرى
واثر بشكل كبير على شعبيه اكبر تطبيقات
على العالم من ضمنها فيسبوك وايضا
التطبيقات المشابهه في السوشيال ميديا
وهذا ما يشكل تهديد او كبير طبعا
للسيطره الغربيه على
الجانب التكنولوجي والجانب التقني تحاول
الان اداره شركه تيك توك من يعني تقديم
بعض التنازلات من خلال وضع اليه مراقبه
وايضا عمليات تقلل من كيفيه حصول الاداره
على البيانات وبالتالي خصوص البيانات
المواطنين في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لانه حسب القوانين الامريكيه ان لا يجوز
لاي شركه اجنبيه ان تقوم
بمشاركه او استغلال المعلومات التي تعتبر
او تصنف بانها معلومات حساسه معلومات يمكن
ان تحدد شخصيه اي شخص او اي فرد فيه
المجتمع الامريكي حسب القوانين الامريكيه
هذا يعتبر اخلال ومن هنا ينطلق الكثير من
المشرعين الامريكيين لاستخدام هذه
الفقره وهذا الجزء من القانون
بشكل عام من اجل يعني
الضغوطات على شركه تيك توك اذا انت الثالث
اول عشرين من مارس سيكون هذا يوما مهما
لتيكتور حيث سيمثل الرئيس التنفيذي
للتطبيق امام مجلس النواب الامريكي ماذا
يمكن ان يقدم
عدا عن مراكز حفظ البيانات التي قدمت
سابقا سواء في فرجينيا او في سنغافوره ما
الذي لدى التطبيق ليقنع الولايات المتحده
بانه تطبيق لا
ليس ضالعا في عمليات التجسس التي يتهم بها
بالحقيقه التطبيق هو ليس فقط يشكل هاجسا
ضد الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بل ايضا
سبق ذلك كثير من البلدان التي قامت بحظر
هذا التطبيق من ضمنها الهند وايضا
دول عده في العالم
والسبب فعليا انه فعلا تطبيق التيك توك
يحصل على صلاحيات واسعه على اجهزه
المستخدمين ويمكن من خلال هذه الصلاحيات
جمع معلومات وايضا تنصت واستخدام بعض يعني
المنافذ المفتوحه من اجل جلب معلومات وليس
بالضروره ان يكون طبعا من الشخص المباشر
بل اي شخص بالعائله داخل المنزل يستخدم
تطبيق تيك توك ايمكن فعليا يعني سحب
معلومات اصوات
ذلك الحال دكتور انس مع جميع التطبيقات
الاخرى يعني نعلم ان هناك دول في الاتحاد
الاو روبي قادت مثلا جوجل وفيسبوك على
تسريب بيانات على الدخول الى بيانات
المستخدمين هذا هذا لا ينطبق على جميع
مواقع التواصل وعلى جميع التطبيقات
طبعا التطبيقات بشكل عام تخترق قوانين
الخصوصيه ولكن هذه التطبيقات الغربيه
عندما تعمل داخل حدود الاتحاد الاوروبي
فهي تعمل بطريقه مختلفه عن باقي دول
العالم وبالتالي اخضع طبعا قوانين الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذه التطبيقات على العمل بطريقه
لا تخالف القوانين ولا طبعا تحاول ان
تستغل او تنتهك الخصوصيه وبالتالي هذا ما
نحاول ان نرى هذا السيناريو ايضا انه ان
تعمل تطبيقات التيك توك الصينيه والتي
فعلا هي
مملوكه للشركات
يعني ودول قد تكون منافسه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تعمل ضمن الاطر
والقوانين المحليه الامريكيه وبالتالي سوف
تختلف بشكل كبير عن استخدام هذه التطبيقات
خارج الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طبعا
طبعا شركه تيك توك بدات
بالكثير من المبادرات سبيل المثال
بتخزين المعلومات على يعني على سحابه طبعا
شركه امريكيه موجوده في الولايات المتحده
الامريكي ولكن هذا يبدو انه لحد الان غير
كافي ما زال كثير من طبعا هنالك الخوف
والقلق من هذه التقنيات الصينيه والشركات
الصينيه بانه فعليا حتى لو تم تخزين هذه
البيانات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يجب تغيير اليه عمل الخوارزميات بحيث انها
لا تؤثر او تلاعب او تؤثر على يعني
التفكير وراي الاشخاص طبعا واضحه الصوره
دكتور اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت معنا الدكتور
انس النجداوي الاكاديمي والمستشار في
اداره العمل الرقميه والتقنيه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
بعد نحو عقدين من محادثات بلغت ذروتها في
سباق شاق على مدى الايام القليله الماضيه
في نيويورك وافقت غالبيه الدول على لغه
لمعاهده تاريخيه للامم المتحده من شانها
حمايه التنوع البيولوجي للمحيطات نظرا لان
الحياه البحريه تواجه تهديدات جمه من تغير
المناخ والصيد الجائر وامكانيه التعدين في
قاع البحار فان المعاهده ستجعل من الممكن
انشاء مناطق محميه بحريه
وتدابير سن تدابير حمايه اخرى في اعالي
البحار الامتداد الهائل للمحيطات التي
تغطي تقريبا نصف العالم
[موسيقى]
لازمنا لم نتعلم دروس البيئه التي تصرخ
بها الارض والسماء والبحار وصولا الى
قاعها الى التراث المشترك للبشريه
التنقيب عن المعادن في اعماقها كنز مدمر
تتقاسمه بعض اكبر اقتصادات العالم وبعض
المساهمين والمستثمرين على حساب الدول
الناميه والفئات الضعيفه والحياه البحريه
وعن ماذا يبحثون
عن المعادن الرئيسه المستخدمه في تصنيع
السيارات الكهربائيه والبطاريات هذه
الثوره نحو مكافحه التلوث والحفاظ على
البيئه تدمرها في مكان اخر مؤسسه العداله
البيئيه غير الحكوميه تقول ان اثر التنقيب
البحريه على النظم الايكولوجيه الهشه لا
يمكن عكسه الكائنات الحيه الملتصقه
بالمعادن او التي تم تكمن في طريق مركبات
التعدين تسحق وتمزق وستستغرق عقودا
للتعافي للتعاثت حقوقه الاستكشاف في اعماق
البحار تتركز في ايدي عدد قليل من البلدان
سبعه منها تمتلك ما يقرب من ثلثي عقود
الاستكشاف احدى وثلاثين الممنوحه حتى الان
الصين وروسيا كوريا الجنوبيه وفرنسا
المانيا والهند والياباني
الصين لها حصه الاسد هي اكبر مساحه تمثل
18% من المناطق المكتشفه منذ 2001
حمله التنقيب الموسعه ستنطلق في 2024 تشهد
معارضات حكوميه وبيئيه تهدد استخراج رواسب
تقدر بذر اليونايتد الدولارات كوبالت
ومنجنيز وغيرها من سيفوز هذه المره انصار
البيئه اما لطالم غلبها
وصلنا الى نهايه حلقتنا لليوم وتتابعنا في
حلقه يوم السبت من الساعه 60 جيش اسرائيل
مهدد احتجاجات تتسع وبوادر عصيان عسكري
فقر متعدد الابعاد في لبنان ومحافظات
الشمال
المتضرر الاكبر
في نهايه الساعه ابرز احداث الساعه بصور
من الان وحتى الساعه المقبله انا حنين
الشولي وهذه الساعه 60
[موسيقى]